welcome back over 1 000 members of the
entertainment industry have signed an
open letter
calling for a change in culture it's
following allegations
made against noel clarke he has denied
allegations of sexual misconduct or
criminal behavior
but has said that he will be seeking
professional help to educate himself
well the letter says after reading the
null clark allegations many of us within
the tv and film industry
started sharing our own stories of
sexual harassment and sexual abuse
his case is not a one-off and shockingly
is not
an extreme example it is time to rethink
the culture of tv
and film it is time to put an end to
this culture
that turns a blind eye to predators and
harassers
operating in plain sight
well that letter was written by muriel
beale who is a freelance producer and
officer
for the beck to trade union muriel good
evening
to you you will know as well as i will
that changing a culture isn't going to
happen because you've written a letter
yes hello samantha no i mean you'll
understand this industry of course
um we've got a lot of work to do but
the reason i wrote the letter in the
first place was because
when that story came out about noel
clarke um
there was an absolute outpouring all my
whatsapp
messages lit up with people
sharing their own stories and it seems
to me that pretty much
every woman that i know who works in tv
and film
has got a story not about noah clarke
but about
another man um and
that really struck me as something that
was being normalized
but isn't normal and something that's
being
accepted but isn't acceptable you say in
your letter that that it's it that it's
in plain sight
and i'm wondering it's about a month
since those guardian
articles were published about the
allegations against noel clarke
and i'm not encouraging you to name
names at all uh this evening but
i'm just wondering you know given
the proliferation of stories out there
as as you say
why more names haven't come up
i mean it's a very complicated situation
i think mornings might come out
um people are quite scared
it's a freelance industry um people at
the top
tend to be staff and then the workforce
tends to be freelance and then what that
means of course is that you're
constantly looking for your next job
you're constantly thinking about when
your next pay package will come in
and how it will come in you're working
on your reputation
so people are still worried about
speaking up
um and there is a lot of bullying going
on generally in the industry that we
need to tackle but
particularly with focus on women it
really just struck me
that uh sexism seems to be
rife after all this time yeah i mean you
mentioned
microaggressions in there uh the
low-level hum
of sexism let's just tell us a bit about
how that feels when you're at the
receiving end of it and how it manifests
well i mean i gave a few examples in the
letter um i think
it's incredibly difficult if you are a
junior
woman in the industry and you are
perhaps the only woman in the room
how do you deal with comments about
your appearance or what people want to
do to you
or what you could do for them how do you
know where to turn and how do you know
where to take
that i think if people are moving around
in an industry it's not clear
where um who they can trust really
i'm wondering how much of it is is a
male female
thing and how much of it is is a power
thing because you have
it is an industry where there is
there is a huge asymmetry in demand and
supply isn't there i mean so many people
who want to be on screen
people who want to be screenwriters and
there aren't that many opportunities and
that creates
a power structure
yeah there's huge competition i mean god
it's a fantastic industry to be in
that's why we're here when it all works
together it's it's
fantastic you know you've got a
brilliant team everything's going well
you don't want it you don't want to
leave
um and we want the men on our side it's
really important that the men are our
allies and i was really happy to see
lots of men
signing the letter and putting their
names to the letter and asking for
change lots of
high-profile men as well as crew
did any men that you approached about
this not want to sign the letter
um no and actually i didn't really
approach that many people
personally it's just taken flights and
gone off on its own accord and what
specifically mary
are you asking for and what do you think
you might be able to realistically
achieve with it
i think you know as i say it's a very
complicated situation um
but i think there's a disconnect between
the workforce who are actively
wanting change and desperate for change
and the people at the top who maybe
haven't quite realized that
and people are getting really angry and
really upset
and it's time to really focus on that
get together
discuss things and work out what we can
do going forward
there's different there's different
ideas being suggested like a
a mental first aider mental health first
aider
um or uh you know an equivalent of
um a covert supervisor but you can have
a mental health first lady instead
somebody that's there that's independent
that you can turn to
as a safe trusted person to speak to
well really interesting to talk to
you'll be interesting to see as well
how many signatories you get on that
letter thank you for your time on sky
news